talk about it starfield ended the show i
gotta say watching the trailer
breathtaking it's one of those things
from the different locations and just
seeing the difference between that moon
versus the populated city just amazing
the dog fighting uh the just everything
was so awesome the team really outdid
themselves it's one of those things
about a bethesda games studios game that
i always love and it's been the case
honestly since you know i i worked on
morrowind and oblivion and all those
games that you know we talked about and
ever for every single one you cannot pin
people down to oh it's about this
because it's not like ultimately what
those games are are massive sandboxes
where they give players just ridiculous
amounts of freedom to say you go figure
out what kind of game you want to play
and what kind of experience you want to
have because that's what this game is
about it's not us prescribing and saying
you have to do these things and like no
it's about creating this huge
uh sandbox with over a thousand planets
so you can completely explore and say
yeah but you don't have to like it's
entirely up to you to figure out what
what is fun for me do i want story do i
want to join factions do i want to you
know build outposts and gather resources
to build more cool stuff the team really
puts all of those tools in the player's
hands and step back and says
now it's time for you to tell the story
of starfield which is your story which
is going to be different than mine which
is going to be different than everybody
else's and i think that's that's really
where the magic of a bethesda game
studios game happens speaking about the
scope of everything todd said this is
what an epic rpg
is what what does bethesda define an
epic rpg as i think again it's it's sort
of leaning into look there's a lot of
folks who take a lot of different
approaches on what is an open world mean
and bethesda game studios always pushes
themselves to the most freedom and least
limitations right where the items in the
world are all real things you walk into
a store and there's a bunch of weapons
or whatever like that's not just art on
a countertop like you could pick those
up you could steal them and run out of
it you can create chaos like we don't
want to put too many limits on what the
player is or isn't allowed to do we love
it when players say i wonder what
happens if and then they try it and then
they get to see like oh my lord chaos
ensued and it was insanity everybody was
shooting at me and like that's i think
the beauty of bethesda game studios and
the and the number of ways that they
push for you to explore that right it's
not just one it's
you could spend thousands of hours doing
nothing but shipbuilding and like focus
that as all you're about and that's okay
but you could also be about exploring
every planet and finding all of the good
and that's okay or you can just play the
main story and be like i want a kind of
experience that i'm guided through so
that i kind of get to see stuff and i
might stop here and there oh there's a
cool side quest that i got but you know
i want something that sort of leads me
through because i'm a little you know it
could be a little daunting to say you
can go do whatever i want like oh i
don't know what i should do so
some folks want a little bit of a guided
path or to understand where the fun is
and no approach is wrong like for me
that's epic because it says we aren't
putting any limits on what you can or
can't do we're going to set you loose
and just sit back and watch the the
beauty that you create with your own
stories and the way that you solve
problems or choose to spend your time in
this world we've created i love that and
i you know what you said about um you
know those moments that maybe you
experience that i don't like those are
some of the best moments if i think back
to playing rpgs when i'm discussing with
my friends oh did you see that no i
didn't see it where did you see it and
having them go out and find it so i
think that's going to be one of those we
talk about that a lot that sort of water
cooler moment like you come in the next
day and you talk to everybody about what
you did and you were like wait i did
that quest but i did this completely
different thing and you sort of start to
appreciate all of the choices that you
could have made you didn't even realize
were an option like oh i didn't even
think about doing that like oh yeah i
just ran in and stole his ship and shot
all of his crew members and took off
like you can do that like oh yeah you
can do anything like that i think that
is
um a special part of the bethesda game
studios game and and when we say epic
rpg we mean all of the stories all of
them all right you just gave me some
ideas for stealing people's ships uh so
i appreciate that uh that's gonna be top
on the list to do in starfield now um we
saw quite a bit of combat and action in
the game that seems to also be in in
addition to exploring and everything
that seems to be another huge focus of
that absolutely i mean you know look if
you look at a game like skyrim which
like everybody's played skyrim at this
point
it can you know a combat is a big part
of that unless you decide it's not like
if you're one of those folks that says
actually i'm going to do the alchemy
thing and i just go off and pick flowers
and make potions and like
live another life in another world this
way then combat isn't part of it but
look we know in an epic rpg there's
always bad people they you know shooting
at you sometimes you got to return fire
and there's a lot of fun to be had there
and so you know providing a lot of
different skills that sort of determine
how good you are in combat combined with
all the different weapons in the game
and then you layer in ship combat and
all these other things it starts to sort
of paint a picture of just how
broad or how deep the rabbit hole goes
it's going to be so impressive um and
you touched on it a little bit and i
want to talk about it because this was
one watching the the video the demo on
what i saw and it really caught my eyes
around the ship um it's not just getting
in the ship and that's your ship there's
so much behind it
a little bit yeah like every ship is
customizable to the nth degree and not
just like cosmetically i want my ship to
look like this or look like that though
obviously that's totally the thing that
you could do if all you care about is
cosmetics but it goes much deeper than
that in terms of like what kind of
shield you have what kind of weapons you
have like what kind of ship are you
building what do you want it to be good
at what trade-offs are you willing to
make or not and then the other part of
it is of course well you can't just like
it's a spaceship those aren't cheap so
you have to figure out like how am i
going to do this where do i get the
resources to build this stuff what kind
of you know skills do i need to level up
to improve different parts of my ship
beyond you know what i could do without
those skills so there's a lot of again
choices in terms of you get to decide
that how much you want to put into that
or not do you just want to give somebody
money for the parts that you want you
want to build it all of those things are
sort of part of the fun of deciding how
much do you want to interact with this
and how do you want to interact with it
absolutely i mean just as you mentioned
the scope the level of player agency
something that i feel like is going to
just make starfield such a special
experience so between red fall esl
fallout 76 and starfield you all are
just
coming yeah we got a few games coming
out it's gonna be so great um pete thank
you so much for stopping by thanks for
having me of course of course pete